wird mark zuckerbergs meadows schon bald
realität wird unsere welt eine andere
das wirft allerdings einige fragen auf
denn das messer es ist ja keine realität
sondern virtuell eine art künstlicher
parallelwelt die wir aber als teil
unserer welt erleben erschaffen von mark
zuckerberg firma med aber wenn alle
menschen die gleichen virtuellen
ergänzungen der realität sehen sind sie
dann nicht schon realität es ist schon
verrückt und vielleicht wird es noch
verrückter wenn das match race ohne mark
zuckerberg realität wird denn auch das
ist ein realistisches szenario klicks um
science and future geht es dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen dieses video ist
entstanden in kooperation mit willy de
dem digitalen abos für smartphone oder
tablet für reguläre 9 eur 99 gibt es
nahezu alle magazine und zeitschriften
der link ist hier unter me und mit einem
hammer sonderangebot für euch ihr
bekommt einen monat umsonst und erst ab
dann kostet es 999 und es kann vorher
und ansonsten jederzeit gekündigt werden
und wir haben dieses man muss sagen
meter spannende thema dort auf wti in
technology review gefunden der
zeitschrift sms massachusetts institute
of technology magazin gibt es auf
deutsch und es ist auch teil von ried
league mit tausenden zeitschriften auch
eben aus dem bereich wissenschaft ich
habe mir hier meine favoriten
zusammengestellt und stürmer auch dort
immer wieder nach den neuesten
entwicklungen ich kann mir lesezeichen
setzen und habe so immer einen ganzen
zeitungskiosks dabei bzw noch viel mehr
ohne einen anhänger hinterher ziehen zu
müssen wer erinnert sich noch an second
life auch das war oder ist ein
metaversum oder matters allerdings ist
es eine parallelwelt und die
berührungspunkte mit unserer welt sind
nur punktuell damals gab es dort
autohäuser shops botschaften und auch
ich hatte dort ein avatar und eines
abends trafen wir uns dort um eine apple
keynote mit freunden zusammen anzusehen
und es fühlte sich tatsächlich irgendwie
real an mann hatte ein wenig das gefühl
tatsächlich dort gewesen zu sein heute
mit 3d brillen später mal mit einer art
kodex prototypen dafür gibt es ja schon
könnte das noch viel beeindruckender
sein und in der zeit von pandemien
hätten wir es vielleicht zu schätzen
gewusst in eine virtuelle parallelwelt
zu entkommen wo alles etwas normaler als
in unserer welt gewesen wäre so paradox
das auch gewesen wäre also schnell zeigt
sich wenn so eine welt normaler als die
realität sein kann wenn sie bedürfnisse
stillen kann die in einer pandemie
zumindest in der realität unerfüllt
bleiben dass da etwas dran ist was ist
also dran am meter words von mark
zuckerberg das alles und noch viel mehr
jetzt hier bei pixum science im future
mal gesagt hat scheint alles auf eine
karte zu setzen auf die messkarte sein
unternehmen hat er schon umbenannt in
matter und jetzt soll bei meta also das
metall war es realität werden wobei
magdeburg offenbar selbst noch nicht so
genau weiß was er da erschaffen will zum
ersten mal erwähnt wird das metall es im
buch no crash von neal stephenson aus
dem jahr 1992 dort gibt es auch zum
ersten mal avatare das meta groß ist
dort eine art fusion von realität und
virtueller realität und wird so zu einer
art neuer welt es ist also mehr als in
matrix oder reggae player haben
vielleicht so ein bisschen wie im neuen
film frida wo die player im gegensatz zu
den nicht player charakteren eine
virtuelle ergänzte realität sehen
virtuelle und reale realität
verschmelzen und irgendwann weiß man
vielleicht gar nicht mehr ob man sich in
der echten welt oder in einem virtuellen
spiel befindet mark zuckerberg meint
dass das der teleportation am nächsten
kommt im version ist das stichwort das
gefühl sich wirklich an einem anderen
ort so befinden das sei eine umwelt in
der wir verkörpert sind oder verkörpert
das internet er weiß wahrscheinlich noch
nicht so richtig wovon er spricht aber
das ist ja auch nicht verwunderlich denn
noch weiß keiner wie das genau aussehen
wird wenn reale welt und virtuelle
verschmelzen vor neid ist vielleicht
schon ein vorgeschmack auch hier hat man
ja eine leben und richtige pop konzerte
gab es ob auch schon im april 2020 sein
12,3 millionen menschen gleichzeitig das
konzert von travis scott informiert wenn
man jetzt diese welt mit unserer welt
authentisch verknüpfen könnte was wäre
wenn wir ein spezielles outfit von
fordert auch in unserer realen welt
tragen könnten das wäre nicht nur
ökologisch sondern würde ihren wert auf
steigern und weitergedacht stadt
videokonferenzen könnten wir uns in der
realität virtuell treffen wenn es
ausreichend intensiv also realistisch
wäre bräuchte man keine flugreisen mehr
konferenzen inklusive networking könnten
virtuell stattfinden es ist schon
verdammt verführerisch doch es gibt auch
eine kehrseite
wie will facebook verzeihung männer das
managen schon heute bekommt es der
konzern nicht hin hetze und lügen zu
verbannen erst gerade musste das
bundesverfassungsgericht den konzern
dazu verurteilen den opfern hetzer daten
zur verfügung zu stellen damit diese von
den juristisch belangt werden können ich
vermisse da leider die sittliche reife
bei mark zuckerberg und seinem konzern
so etwas überhaupt managen zu können da
sieht man ja schon die impfgegner demos
mit virtuell blinkenden und lernenden
schildern braut die präsente beim sak
berg spricht zwar von einem meter groß
mit vielen unternehmen die beteiligt
sind allerdings so kennt man sascha burg
unter seiner führung und neben der
kehrseite gibt es noch einen haken und
das ist die technik zwar meinen
befürwortete das einen meter groß auch
mit smartphones und computern
funktioniert aber letztlich wird es erst
etwas wenn wir die zweite realität auch
wie selbstverständlich mit wa headsets
also diesen dicken apparaten virtual
reality oder
brillen bringen für die ergänzte
realität die argumente trelle ti sehen
können niemand rennt mit den klobigen wa
headsets durch sein echtes leben manche
meinen auch was die 2,3 milliarden die
mark zuckerberg schon vor jahren für den
hersteller von wa headsets oculus rift
ausgegeben hat eine fehlinvestition ist
und die gibt es noch gar nicht schon der
erste anlauf mit google glas war ein
desaster niemand möchte eine brille die
ihre umgebung fotografiert und filmt
jemand der eine solche brille trägt wird
ausgestoßen das ist das cookie vom
gegenüber möglicherweise gefilmt und
fotografiert zu werden deshalb ist es
wohl auch keine gute idee vom wetter
zusammen mit ray ban genau eine solche
brille noch einmal zu entwickeln stories
soll sie heißen spricht man sollte mit
stories für facebook und instagram
aufnehmen oder klarer formuliert der
konzern der bisher nicht gerade durch
den verantwortungsvollen umgang mit
daten aufgefallen ist will im
öffentlichen raum beständig daten
sammeln doch das meta wörz wird kommen
nur nicht so wie es sich mag aber
wahrscheinlich vorstellt auch apple
arbeitet schon seit jahren an einer
brille dürfte die eben nicht grenzenlos
daten sammeln und sein gegenüber ständig
filmen und fotografieren und im
gegensatz zu facebook meter ist apple da
schon ein stückchen weiter im app store
gibt es bereits 14.000 augmented reality
apps da können möbel virtuelle in die
eigene wohnung gestellt werden man kann
brillengestelle auf dem eigenen gesicht
ausprobieren ein porsche konfigurieren
und damit herumfahren und natürlich ohne
ende games spielen apples managers ist
damit schon bedeutend weiter als das von
meta facebook weil es damit bereits
unendlich viel praktische erfahrung
gesammelt hat und bei der auswertung
sind die daten mit differenziert privacy
unkenntlich gemacht worden und anonym
und wie bei apple wo die daten schon vor
der kommunikation der cloud anonymisiert
werden muss dann die privatsphäre
geschützt werden etwas woran der
datensammel konzern facebook meter gar
kein interesse hat wer will denn von
einer solchen firma dann hardware kaufen
die genau das datensammeln zum ziel hat
es wird also wahrscheinlich wirklich so
sein dass das messer erst das nächste
große ding wird aber nicht diese welt zu
programmieren wird die große
herausforderung sondern dass die weiß
die brille die das technisch auch
ermöglichen wird und die wird erst mal
ziemlich simpel und sich erst langsam
entwickeln und dann braucht es wie das
internet einen industriestandard für
diese welt und datenschutz ist da die
nummer eins anforderungen womit der mark
zuckerberg meines erachtens raus wäre
das thema stammt aus viply.de ich nur
sowie die schon einige jahre weil es
dort einfach alles gibt und dass auch
viel ausführlicher als so im netz wie
zum beispiel hier mark zuckerbergs meter
groß aus technology review
für dieses magazin lohnt sich das video
aber es gibt noch weitere 5000 magazine
und mehr auf willi das sonderangebot für
euch gibt es hier einfach draufklicken
der link ist übrigens auch in der video
beschreibung und als erster kommentaren
gepinnt das ist ein echter mehrwert also
drauf klicken und los geht's bis dahin
bleibt an